foreign
[Music]
two days ago a Strike Team assassinated
President Udo
and yet you cannot prove that we weren't
involved doesn't that concern you no sir
it terrifies me you need to manage this
Jack yes sir what are you going to tell
them this corruption goes way higher
than the CIA hey buddy say welcome I
figured we could use the help wish me
luck good luck
[Music]
give me everything you can I'm Domingo
Chavez
on paper you might be the deadliest
operator the cia's ever employed I need
to find out who's behind all this to be
honest with you you're a lot of God
see this
now I'm blushing
so what are we getting at convergence
diffusing of a drug cartel with a
terrorist organization
they can move anything humans weapons
suicide bombers unlimited resources
paired with undying hatred
[Music]
not on my watch
the world is a game board of changing
hands
nothing but vipers Beyond these walls
you do not know who these people are
sure I'll meet him soon enough
Jack is out there risking his life
I always wanted to be a federal Ally
just the CIA was second fourth
what the hell are you sure you want to
know
what do you say he hung up on me typical
[Applause]
[Music]